Yaron Carni
thank you so much for joining me on
20 minute leaders
my pleasure
thank you for having me
you're calling from Israel, right?
I am
how is everything over there?
things are starting to get back to some
form of normalization starting this week
but it's way too early to assess
I myself am still at home
yeah, you will
You know, this is going to be
broadcasted in just a few weeks
so hopefully by then we'll keep
on the optimism and and they're starting
to open up or we fully opened up
but we'll see
and let me doubt it
but let's see
We'll see, we'll see
OK, Yaron, such a great pleasure
thank you so much
founder of Maverick Partners
you're on the board of of some incredible
organizations that we'll touch upon
A contributor at Forbes
I've been falling for a long time in a big fan,
and I'd love to spend these 20
minutes to sort of pick your brain
and have a discussion on what it's like to
open up a venture capital firm
in a pretty non-traditional way like
you did while at the same time really
being a core part of these
organizations and companies
so maybe, give me a quick rundown of what
happened in your life that led to Maverick
and then joining these awesome companies
so OK, so that goes back to my schooling
I wouldn't know school specifically
yeah,
I studied
I grew up in the States
for a bunch of years
I'm Israeli born, grew up in the States
and then moved back to Israel to finish
high school, do the army and all that
and then I started studying here
in Israel at the IDC at the Zell program
I was in the second Zell Program class
wow
and I just did a talk with Liat Aaronson
I don't know if she was
the director back then
she wasn't
she wasn't born then
when I, when I was a student
and she's terrific,
she's a force behind the program,
definitely last many, many years,
over a decade, of course, anyhow
so I study there and I was always
an entrepreneur,
from a very young age myself, really
dabbling in every kind of different
feel that you could imagine
I was always
attracted to setting up companies
and setting up businesses and sailing
I sailed a lack with a lot of different,
different ideas
and a bit after the my first degree,
my bachelor degree, I flew back to New
York and I worked there with my brother
he had a promotional staffing agency like
H.R. Platform at the Times are independent
contractors that he had founded,
called G.C. Marketing
and I went back and helped
him with the company
and about a year later, we found
a buyer who we sold the majority
holdings to the company to
and I decided to come home
back home to Israel and
I came back and I was
looking for what to do
and then
I was, actually I started my master's
degree in IP law
and I decided that I would be
very attracted to the whole field
of technologies
was that really a first interception
with technology when you
did your masters in IP
is that when you really got into it
I think during the Zell program,
I was most exposed to it
and I'm actually goes back
the story connects and you're even
connected to it, to this story indirectly,
you yourself
and then I, I decided, I teamed up
with with a friend from New York who is
a very successful businessperson
who I met actually also my studies
and he had sold his company in the States
and he said, you know what, let's start
I keep hearing about Israeli innovation
let's start an angel group together
in which we will invest in very
early stage Israeli companies
so I was, it was basically, you know,
everyone had that moment in their life,
yet completely changed their life
that was my moment
wow
I mean, to this day,
it's probably my moment
and I remember that call and I said,
all right, great
and I started looking
for startups to invest in
and I was you know, I was
looking for things for quite a long time
and I couldn't find anything
that I really like
and so I this I thought at the time that,
you know, basically I'm screwed in a way
where this is just too difficult to do
and then out of nowhere,
I was very, very lucky to have
to have been X to have remained
my classmate from the Zell
program of dead contact
he had set up a company with
four other founders that was called
Lappe Pixie's yeah I Pixie's data widgets
for I Google, I Google is the
equivalent of say the App Store nowadays
but this was prehistoric
on such a long time ago
I remember it from my childhood
exactly
and that company I remember it launched
in the first first day
and made five dollars
wow
this is an amazing company
because there's so much potential
and we, I ended up convincing my partner
to invest and he thought it was you know,
he didn't really connect to it as much
and we thought a million
dollars in the company
I'd put a hundred thousand dollars
in the company, which was all I had
and, you know, it was
all the money saved up
and you know long journey
I also became the the head
of this debt at the company
so I was both in the investment
proactively, actively involved
we also also invested in six other six
companies in total
and that company larynxes
and they'd be ended up being the first
Israeli company to be sold to Google
wow
the Google guy
and
he was based in the States at the time
and we started talking
that led to a relationship
that was really amazing
and then the deal was done very quickly
and it was really a true pleasure
to work with Google in this process
and then at the time made me quite known
in the market and I got a lot
of deal flow off the site
right
as I mentioned earlier,
we had invested in six companies
yeah, well, two of them folded
and for them, we were able to sell
wow
that's considered a very
lucky track record
yeah, of course
and, but I love that
I love being able to find entrepreneurs
at a very early stage
I love being able to help them,
you know, with everything and anything
you can imagine really being one
of them as a founder in a way
so it's some of the companies, you know,
buyers don't touch,
of course, to this every day
but some of them, you know, we have all
the growing pains that they had suffered
we aren't sure with them
how tight was your
relationship with your with your
founders and your first investments?
because, you know, now that it's all over
the spectrum, some some investors
like to be very hands on
some of them are very, you know,
talk to me every quarter
well, what was
extremely I mean, daily, almost daily
oh wow
yeah at least several times a week
nowadays
by the way, we're still
very actively involved
that's a fund also
almost the same level of intensity because
we believe that that's
what we can provide
apart from money, you know,
it's the added value component
but what I learned in that in that angel
group, which is called
the Tel Aviv Angel Group
Yep
Is the importance of working with your
investors and getting as much added value
from them as possible because everybody
has the ability to be helpful
to the companies they just need
to be helpful
totally
and that's the point total,
and you need to know how to motivate them
and how to get their attention and all
these people, even though likely
this won't change their lifestyles
the company does it, right well,
they still want to be helpful
and they find the companies
interesting both
and then they come nudnik perspective,
but also, you know, challenging
in other forms an adult's interest
they like to be helpful to the companies
based on what they're doing
interesting
right
so what is that?
what is maverick actually?
What what does that name stands for?
Maverick
Maverick actually sort of is the next
generation step of of them have the
Tel Aviv Angel group that I've founded
and the word maverick was chosen
because of the dual meaning
we all know what a maverick means
in English, but in Hebrew maverick
it's not sleek
that's art to shine, to be
a genius idea
and that's what that's the
origin of this name
so we're Maverick Ventures, Israel
that's the name of the fund
we have two funds
our first fund was just a bit
over 40 million dollars
the second fund was over
75 million dollars
wow
and now we are in the process of
fundraising for our search fund
wonderful
so how many companies
have invested in so far?
we've invested in 35 companies I believe
wow
last year was very, very active
I think we were one
of the most active funds
it's not the in Israel, but we don't tend
to promote any of the deals that we do
I'm not against it if other firms do
but we ourselves or the company does
we ourselves
relatively shy away from proactive
public relations at this time
until, God willing, we
succeed in one of the companies
something interesting happens
with the companies and we're very happy
our approach is to try to be relatively
modest and we can at this stage
so give me maybe, you know,
two or two or three very quick
intuitions that you're looking for as
as you're approaching
due diligence about it
I'm assuming this is more
seed stage right for now
we do early growth,
our cheque size is usually
up to five million dollars
wow, ok,
two to five million dollars
is our
so I no longer do the stuff
I did with the angel group
we tried to go
we only look for companies that already
have initial traction in revenue
and we try to help them
scale up as much as we can
we have over 100 investors, 100 LPC
so what I had before in the four to six
investors in the Angel group
just did the same thing
much bigger
and all these people, as I said,
some of them are extremely helpful
you probably know several of them
and they are people that come from all
fields, from that Cadena,
from different businesses
we have business women and men from
all walks of life that you can imagine
so what what are some of the challenges
of running a fund with over 100 LP is
because on one hand you want to really
utilize their their strong backgrounds
and their expertise, whether it's
in due diligence or in deal sourcing
but at the same time, you sort of have
to please a hundred different people
and you know the saying,
you put a hundred percent right two Jews
in a room, you get six opinions
so I can't imagine what
so not Jewish, by the way
they're not only Jewish people thank God
we have people from all walks of life and all
ethnicities, all backgrounds
and happily the people who invest
in maverick, don't invest in mavericks
because of the, say, ethnical aspect
of it being a Jewish homeland
and so on, they just think it's a place
that they can get a high return on
and then how do you balance
how do you balance this expectation
that you'll please everybody while
at the same time
never please anybody
you never please anybody
but you need to first of all, you need
to do a few things, first and foremost
and I say this to every person
who wants to be coming out
and the company is I bluntly tell them
there's a very good chance you'll lose all
your money investing in venture
funding in our venture fund
it makes sense
as well
secondly, we try, we don't try to please
them, but we do try to do
is to do everything possible to reach
the best outcome we can
and to be a go between their
abilities and their connections
and what the companies seek
so each one of these investors in our
mindset has the ability to be helpful
to each one of the companies,
to many of their companies,
people who have gone to like
imagine you in 10 years from now
you'll you know, you will
have your alumni association
you'll have all the friends that you've
had, your past jobs in education
and so on and so forth
and you'd like to be helpful
to the companies where you'd also like us
to be as respectful
to your time as possible
so we like to keep to make sure that we
know exactly what each person
could bring to the table
on one hand and then the other hand,
not to assume that you do
not have connections to
A juice manufacturer in Australia
because maybe you randomly do
and so we tried to sort of, you know,
plan that thin line and be still very
respectful to the to the LPs time
and the way we do this is we send
a quarterly report and then we have to do
a page at the very beginning with what
with three points at each company,
like assistance
interesting,
say, staffing up position like a CFO
they're looking for a CFO
to open an office in the east coast
they want, you know, a connection
to this or that conglomerate
or as anybody has
no experience in a specific tax question
that they may have,
and you will just know, right, that
oftentimes people have something to add
and that's what differentiates us
we act with the same
passion that we had as an Angel group
I want to believe we have the same thing
now when when it's people's private money
it's different than when you're,
of course, and you have raised
money from institutional
and again, of course, not all
the LPs are, you know, very active
many of them surprise you
of course, yeah
no, I have to say that, you know,
I'm a part I'm with a now
at J-Ventures and I and we
also we are a great guy
yeah
over 100 LPS
and it's just so humbling to see that,
you know, people are people are
putting their time, their effort
and I keep
and it's amazing how much of it
they put in and how
willingly they want to help
and when it's not, you know,
for a salary of or because they have to,
but because they want to,
they raise their hand and say, yeah,
I want to be a part of this, of this
company and its due diligence
or this or helpless portfolio
you see so much value that they bring and
and you write that out of, over hundred
potential LPs, sometimes get
these jems that are really random
with a connection to a a juice
manufacturer in Australia
Yaron, I have to ask about a hood that's
Allar United, that's a large group and one
of the most inspiring
organizations and entrepreneurship
elements of Israel
talk to me a little bit about it
and what's your role over there?
I will, just before I get into that,
I want to go back one step and say that
our LPS are from all over the place
and thank, thank God,
really one of the best things to have
happen to remember,
we said there is that moment when I
got that phone call from my first part
yeah
and an Angel group
and then the second moment that I had was
when I met who Michel Abadi,
who was my partner, has been my partner
since the inception of the fund of Maverick
he is originally from Brazil
he lives in Israel, though,
now for 16 years,
and his network spans of Latin America,
which is a humungous
area that people tend to forget
yup
you know, when it comes to this field
and we have investors from Europe and from
Australia, from other parts of the world
so we're very heterogeneous
in terms of the backgrounds
amazing
and of course, I have really inhuman
Michelle and I really complement each
other and we work very well together
that's something very important
I can give one tiny advice to all the
inspiring new people watching
if there's anyone watching that wants
to set up a company of any kind
is to always make sure to do that
what is considered counter-intuitive,
which is to not surround yourself
by people that have the same background,
sets you up from school
his background, he's an engineer by trade
he's a banker
he just
we're very different
and we are very, very close and really
complementors,
about this, so also going back to the
fact that we have only private investors,
it's one of the second reason
second reason we only
have private investors
first, of course, is there potential
added value
which has proven
itself time to time again
is the fact that we decided
from the get go to donate two percent
of our funds carry of the success of the fund
to United Hatzalah,
which you mentioned United Hatzalah
in my opinion, it's the most amazing
organization that I've come across
and I think that it embodies two things
that are important to me and to everyone,
which is, again, entrepreneurship,
because what they do is very innovative
what they decided to go against this flow
yeah
and secondly is a very basic
essence of saving lives
take action into their own hands
what's that?
taking action into their own hands?
literally bypassing
not waiting for anyone else
and what they do
they started as a guerilla
operation in a way
and to them, too,
I was introduced by that same farmer
markers from the very beginning
and
what they do is they formed
an organization which is similar to Uber
if you think about it
yup
which is an organization that has over
6000 volunteers spread out
throughout all of Israel
and these are people that go around their
day to day jobs or whatever they're doing
and they have, and they are located
they all have medical training and
equipment and they are
first responders
first to get to the first responders
stabilize, whoever is
injured in car accidents, burse
heart attacks, stabbings, terror attacks
God willing, God forbid they nominate all
these other things and they get
to eighteen hundred calls a day
eighteen hundred calls a day?
yeah
and it's all for free
never charge
anything from anyone ever
I also have a few ambulances to help
transport people who just can't pay
are not able or not willing to pay
for transport to a hospital and all
and they just do good
they have people who help with
psychiatric help and psychological help,
and they help Holocaust survivors
they help the needy
they are basically a bunch of angels that
it's almost a matching organization
and by the way, similar to startup,
you want to make sure that their
money that goes into them is spent
in a lean manner,
of course
and that's something they could see their
money there goes
the vast, vast majority of it
to buying medical supplies
you're not just, you're not just a fan
you are
you're on the board of of United
yeah, I'm on the board for the
past over a decade
incredible
there are many wonderful people
and
I've decided that my start
trumpet left two to only focus on one
thing and to do it as well as you can
and every single person that I meet,
I introduced in praise and talk about this
organization, because this organization is
the essence
of being a light onto the nations, which
is what the Jewish people ought to be
and this is one organization
they are trying to setup all over the world
this isn't a Jewish thing
we we have many, many Muslims and many,
many Christians,
many women, many male, chiaradia,
which is the ultra-Orthodox
totally secular people
and we're doing the same thing all over
the world where we want
people to copy this
we want this
I myself was in Brazil
when they opened it
Lithuania
New Jersey
Jersey City
in other parts of the world
and this is exactly what we want
we want Israel
this is our exit of a startup company
we want this
to go global
I love it
just save millions of lives
Yaron
I can't believe we're
already over 20 minutes
it went by way, way too fast
I have to put you on the spot once
and there and ask you for three words
that you would best describe yourself
or that others would describe you,
whether it's Michelle or
Ellie Bear from United Hatzalah
what are three words that were
really and embrace Yaron Carni
annoying,
good,
funny
and a good friend
I love it to these two people
I love it Yaron
thank you so, so much
stay safe
stay healthy
thank you for the inspiration
thank you so much
thank you